how are you I'm doing great feeling good
feeling very good you know we were just
talking to Brendan and I was saying how
how small the Hollywood Community is
because he's kind of got tentacles in
every category like he's got a
connection to everyone like do you think
about that tonight is it like a family
reunion when you come to this thing
because Hollywood is a small place well
maybe for him but but not for me I'm
just I feel still a little bit new and
I'm getting to be more familiar with
everybody it's starting to feel like a
community for me now which is really
nice is your daughter at home watching
tonight does she I mean because I know
she's still little but like yes she's
two and my friend from high school came
to babysit her today because my parents
are coming uh to the Oscars as well
she's watching like Mama get Glam and
pretty and all of that and what was she
what were the you know the thoughts well
we put a little dress on her as well
and there were so many people over at
the house this morning there was like 10
people over and we're normally very
quiet people but it was so nice to hear
her heavy little feet running throughout
the house and she was very cool with
everybody
yeah it does it was such an intense
performance for you and it was such an
intense movie what was it like when you
get to now come to Ward season kind of
exhale and enjoy it and have fun
it's been a really emotional day
actually because I was just thinking
that the whale premiered way back in
September last year at the Venice Film
Festival so it's been six months that
we've been with this talking about it
and going to events and it's it's coming
to a close and you know so that's
emotional but it's also been a really
beautiful six months and you know we're
always striving still for more
inclusivity more representation does it
sit with you though that this year
there's you there's Stephanie there's
Michelle there's Keith Kwan there's the
Daniels you know there's the movie
everything everywhere all at once that
are really kind of maybe giving people
more of a perspective on the Asian
influence in Hollywood and how important
it is for representation and and showing
people that you know everybody is you
know it should be at the table yes and I
think that people who really care about
representation should be just as
passionate throughout the rest of the
year for a lesser-known filmmakers and
projects like I thought the woman King
Lashana Lynch and tuso and Baidu were so
wonderful in that movie and there's
another film called return to Soul the
entire cast was really amazing in that
so I hope that you know even if things
aren't nominated or award or you know
accoladed I I it doesn't mean that
they're not worthy of an audience's time
so I hope that we can also get that
message out there do you have
butterflies are you just really kind of
cool I'm really good I'm just happy to
be here I really really you look so
happy you look calm okay so I'm looking
at this dress and it is elegant but it's
like business in the front party in the
back
custom dressed by Prada and I just fell
in love with it as just the sketch and
I was so happy when I finally got to put
it on it fit like a glove and it feels
very me I did ask them to add a little
mandarin collar as a little nod to my
roots and I was so happy that they
weren't offended by that and they were
happy to oblige
foreign